davis fortsetzung folgt rp bis nepal hat
viele geschichten aktuelle und
dramatische wendige und heute der zweite
folgt begleitung oder nabe und andrea
wieder ein richtig mount everest und
zweimal mit ihnen erleben wir das
erdbeben aus treuen albträumen werden
anfang april 2015 noch ist der traum vom
everest intakt der höchste berg der welt
sieht norbu andrea und viele andere
magisch an
[Musik]
zwei tage vom basecamp entfernt treffen
orbe und andrea oberhalb von dukla am
sogenannten memorial place ein
gedenksteine und tafeln erinnern eher an
die vielen bergsteiger und sherpas die
am everest ihr leben verloren
bisher sind es über 250 sie ahnen nicht
dass sie neun tagen 18 weitere
dazukommen werden
immer der wind das sieht man an den
gebetsfahnen
[Musik]
das ist der stein von scott fischer das
war eine große tragödie im jahre 1996
damals starben zwölf bergsteigern es
letztes jahr war das die größte tragödie
ist weißt du beim besteigen des apples
geht es nicht nur um fähigkeit und
energie oder dich stark du bist sondern
auch unglück wetter und solche dinge
alles zusammen passt wie bei einem
puzzle das passe gut spielt und alles
passt dann ist die besteigung gut aber
wenn ein teil fehlt keine chance ja es
ist nicht einfach die leute vergessen
das manchmal weil so viele den gipfel
besteigen
es ist immer noch hart das müssen wir
berücksichtigen
wieso der everest andrea
der everest ist faszinierend er ist der
höchste berg der welt
die leute fühlen sich angetan von ihm
und nicht nur bergsteiger mit hilfe des
everest kann man auch großartige dinge
tun
sie hat einen großen traum sie will den
everest besteigen einerseits für sich
aber auch um damit etwas gutes zu tun
es kommt von herzen deshalb unterstütze
ich sie dabei
die verliebten träumen davon mit dem
erfolg vom everest ihr hilfsprojekt
weiter frei hält voranzubringen
das sherpa kinder unterstützt
auch im basecamp ist das wetter schlecht
2015 ist ein spezielles jahr
es hat viel geschneit
russell price und seine sherpas opfern
schank libanesisches gebiet als teil
einer putsche eines feierlichen rituals
bevor es losgeht versuchen die sherpas
mit einer solchen zeremonie gitter milde
zu stimmen
auch us ölpreis ist dabei er leitet seit
21 jahren große expedition die pusher
sehr ernst das bringt uns gutes karma
und eine gute zeit
[Musik]
wie wichtig das ist wird sich noch
zeigen
nach der putzer tanzen alle gemeinsam es
sind tänze auf den sherpa davon
russell hat einen großen kleider sponsor
gefunden der das ganze team ausrichtet
egal ob zahlende teilnehmer oder sherpas
bei ihm werden alle gleich behandelt
[Musik]
zwei tage später sind auch andrea und
norbert camp angekommen
sie wohnen in einem zelt von russell
price und planen zwei tage hier zu
bleiben um informationen für ihre firma
zusammen
danach wollen sie den everest von der
tibetischen nordseite her besteigen
hier habe ich ein badetuch mit meinem
namen
andrea ist das erste mal am fuße des
everest norbu begibt sich inzwischen auf
eine tour durch das basecamp er ist
überrascht von der größe
vor zwei jahren war er zum letzten mal
hier rund 1500 leute leben in dieser
riesigen zeltstadt auf dem kobo
gletscher 500 bergsteiger 500 sherpas
500 hilfskräfte
im moment sind hier 42 expeditionen mit
bewilligung
früher konnte man die gipfel gebühren
nur für eine ganze gruppe bezahlen heute
bezahlt man 1000 dollar pro person
jetzt kann ich also mit einem kunden
eine expedition durch
so sind jetzt einige mit ein bis zwei
handel mit 60 kunden unterwegs immer
mehr kleine und unerfahrene expedition
anbieter drängen dadurch auf den markt
vor allem aus nepal und auch dieses jahr
gibt es kurioses wie diesen chinesen der
seine beine am everest verloren hat und
nun mit prothesen den höchsten berg der
welt bezwingen will oder einen 83
jährigen einen binden und so weiter
zudem gibt es viele leute die erst im
basecamp den richtigen umgang mit pickel
steigeisen und leitern lernen und all
das einzig für ruhm und ehre am er ist
bevor sie zum es kommen sollten sie
zumindest lernen wie man mit eispickel
steigeisen oder leitern umgeht
das rettet leben denn sonst gefährdet
sie die sherpas die davon leben ihnen zu
helfen
verschärft wird die situation durch den
preiskampf für eine expedition zahlt
heute ein teilnehmer zwischen 30 und
65.000 dollar
diese expedition bietet die besteigung
für nur 30.000 dollar an
aber mit 60 teilnehmern und 65 sherpas
das ist viel gespart wird mit weniger
service und mit dem material das man zur
verfügung stellt
die sauerstoffflaschen werden immer
wieder gebrauchte sie sind 15 jahre alt
das ist eine möglichkeit
man bezahlt den sherpas weniger typische
partner viel geld viele dieser
billiganbieter hatten in den letzten
jahren aber immer wieder verletzte oder
tote zu beklagen
norbu will es anders machen er will
besten service mit besten sherpas zum
besten preis bieten ein schwieriges
unterfangen in einem umkämpften markt
[Musik]
vorbild von noro und andrea ist das camp
von russell price
aber das ist das teuerste hier zahlt man
65.000 dollar um auf den everest zu
steigen us ölpreis ist gerade dabei
seine sauerstoffflaschen zu
kontrollieren
ich habe hier 380 sauerstoffflasche aber
in kathmandu über 800 wenn ich alles
zusammenzähle macht das über eine
million us dollar
sie werden zuerst hydrostatische
gereinigt bevor sie wieder gefüllt
werden
ein kompliziertes geschäft die
expeditionen sind sein lebenswerk
er organisiert seit 21 jahren touren auf
das dach der welt und hat ein
eingespieltes team
bei einer großen everest expedition geht
es vor allem um sicherheit sicherheit
sicherheit
es ist nicht nur was auf dem berg
passiert sondern wie wir
sie haben 65.000 dollar bzw
mein job ist es auf ihr investment
aufzupassen
ich muss dafür sorgen dass sie auf den
gipfel kommen aber auch dass sie nicht
sterben hygiene spielt bei russell eine
tragende rolle
auch bei der lagerung der vorräte denn
eine magenverstimmung kann das ende der
expedition bedeuten
er hat es zählte mit teppichboden und
bietet seinen teilnehmern eine warme
dusche an damit sich auf 5.300 64 metern
wohl fühlen und erholen können
daneben stehen saubere wcs all das damit
niemand erkrankt
prunkstück seines camps ist dieser
whiteboard das ist dann der schweizer
erfinder
ich finde es gut die im basecamp zu
haben das ist unser tiger tom white
board außen und tiger halle innen ist
komfort
wir sind 71 tage auf expedition davon
klettern wir zwölf tage der rest ist im
basecamp das ist ein komfortabler platz
für die leute zum lesen spielen für
partys ein soziales zentrum
wir haben ladestationen für batterien
von handys oder laptops und wir bieten
unterhaltung mit einem fernseher parat
mit der satellitenschüssel empfangen wir
bbc cnn usw
was hat das noch mit bergsteigen zu tun
die geräte die heute den everest
besteigen wollen sind dann einen guten
lifestyle zu hause gewöhnt wir geben
ihnen komfort vielleicht etwas zu viel
in einer extremen umgebung
aber das kostet nicht viel mehr
andrea und norbert stehen noch ganz am
anfang ihrer geschäfts karriere
pressepreis ist ihnen weit voraus er ist
schon 21 jahre im geschäft über seinen
service können sie nur staunen ein
unglaubliches zählt das ist die zukunft
von expedition wenn man eine
kommerzielle expedition will braucht man
ein solches zelt vermutlich liegt das
alles über 1000 kilo ein solches zelt
ist mein traum aber ich möchte zwei
davon eines für die kunden und eines für
die stars
beide sollen gleichwertig wo wollt ihr
eure firma positionieren
wir sind speziell wir wollen weder eine
ganz teure noch eine ganz billige firma
sein
wir wollen mithalten aber mit einem
fairen geschäft was die ganze mannschaft
betrifft aber nach einer qualität im
service firma der kontakter
norbu und andrea träumen weiter ihr
geschäftsmodell ist erst am entstehen
in fünf jahren wollen sie so weit sein
um russell price konkurrenz zu machen
über den base camp und dem everest
bricht die nacht herein
es ist der 20 april 2015 fünf tage vor
der katastrophe
der erste tag an dem die sherpas auf der
neuen route durch den ausfall
hochsteigen wollen um die höher
gelegenen lager einzurichten
schon um halb drei uhr machten sich die
sherpas von russell price bereit
vor dem aufbruch gibt es noch eine tasse
tee auch expeditionsleiter russell price
ist anwesend um sie zu verabschieden
[Musik]
um 3 uhr verlassen die sherpas das zählt
es geht los
passt auf ich bin glücklich dass die
boys gehen aber auch traurig denn ich
weiß nicht ob alle zurückkommt
[Musik]
mit dem licht ihrer stirnlampen gehen
sie in den gefährlichen eisfall nachts
denn am tag drohen lavigne jeder sherpa
trägt 18 kilo auf den rippen
[Musik]
bei tagesanbruch wird klar dass sie
nicht allein sind über 200 schärfer sind
an diesem morgen unterwegs
der stromausfall ist dieses jahr noch
extremer als je zuvor
eine lawine donnert nieder
aber zum glück beiträgt
[Musik]
vor der schlüsselstelle inhalte im
sogenannten damit der staub groteske
züge an
fast wie die autos vor dem
gotthardtunnel bei ferienbeginn am damm
sind fünf leitern zusammengebunden die
sherpas können hier nur einzeln
hochsteigen
[Musik]
auf unten im basecamp bericht ertrag an
der letzte von andrea und norbert in
diesem camp
sie wollen den ice vermeiden und den
everest von tibet aus besteigen
ja bereit nach tb zu gehen zum
gleichenberg aber von der anderen seite
hast du gesehen was du hier sehen
wolltest ja ich habe viel gesehen
heute morgen besuchte ich die scherben
es gab zwei große lawinen etwas sollte
das war furchteinflößend
sie gehen jetzt nach tibet
von dort aus ist der aufstieg etwas
sicherer
andrea dass ich die plätze in einem
traum sah ich einen vogel fliegen sehr
nahe bei mir
das ist ein gutes zeichen
andrea und norwegen jetzt zurück nach
kathmandu
von dort wollen sie dann mit den jeep
nach china fahren bis zum nördlichen
base camp in tibet
[Musik]
aber was zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
niemand ahnt
alles kommt ganz anders
o
fünfundzwanzigster april 2015 der tag
der katastrophe
auch in kathmandu bebt die erde
in dem land schäfer sah das ganze land
steht unter schock
im everest basecamp hat die lawine eine
spur der zerstörung hinterlassen
diese bilder wurden von einer kuh
gefilmt die für den sponsor von russell
price arbeitete
wasser sherpas bringen verletzte ins es
zählt das jetzt als sanitätsstation
dient
[Musik]
am nächsten tag werden sie mit dem
helikopter ausgeflogen
[Musik]
furchtbare zerstörungen in kathmandu
die leute gerade in den ruinen nach
menschen
[Musik]
oft finden sie nur leichen
über 8500 tod erfordert das beben
dieser helikopter ist unterwegs nach
lukla er kommt vom everest
sein transport leichen
insgesamt sind es 18 tote und über 50
verletzt
die sherpas haben schreckliches erlebt
ich sah wie ein riesiger eisblock von
puma brach er schleuderte steine und
dreck in die luft
ein treffer mit voller wucht das
baseband alles was ihm im weg war es
erinnert 45 sekunden mit sich einige
leute wurden verwundet kann sie davon
rannten um ihr leben zu retten
einige stürzten ich rannte auch nur mich
in deckung zu bringen
ich fand ein felsbrocken und traute mich
dahinter an seinen schatten
so konnte ich überleben habe ich heute
am rücken verletzt an meiner hand ist
gebrochen
ich würde mich als ich erwarte nach etwa
12 15 minuten war alles um mich herum
verwüstet alles war weg gewesen von der
lawine nach dem beben viele einer
eiswand vom kurier am 15
erinnerst du dich was nachher passiert
geht hab meiner motivation ich erinnere
mich nicht denn ich wurde ohnmächtig nun
hält guckt hier als ich nach einer
halben stunde aufwachte versuchte unser
chefkoch seine hand aus dem eis zu
ziehen
ich konnte ihm dabei helfen aber es
schmerzt denn der esstisch hatte mein
bein getroffen und ich glaube es ist
gebrochen
[Musik]
ich habe nur mit viel glück überlebt
der riesige eisblock der von tumoren
herunter als selbst dicke eisenpfosten
zertrümmert die eislawine ist genau über
unser camp weg getan hat 50 60 meter
weiter oben oder weiteren waren alle
sich die lawine traf genau ins weg durch
die mitte des bsb
und hat uns erzählte zugedeckt die
helikopter bringen immer wieder
touristen aus den umliegenden bergen
nach lukla diese können zahlen sei es
mit ihren versicherungen oder mit ihrem
eigenen geld
die sherpas drängen sich in den
helikopter der indischen armee
dieser fliegt die einheimischen gratis
raus nepalesische armee helikopter sind
nicht zu sehen
der indische heli ist so voll dass er
kaum wegkommt von der landepiste auf
2.860 meter höhe der heli fliegt in
einer stunde nach kottmann
in der hauptstadt sind aus angst vor
nachbeben tausende auf die großen plätze
geflüchtet wo sie in zelten hausen
noch wissen wir nichts von andrea und
norbert außer dass sie unterwegs
richtung tibet waren russell price ist
nicht im basecamp sondern in kathmandu
zwei tage vor dem erdbeben flüge in die
hauptstadt um in seinem büro zu arbeiten
wo hat er das erdbeben erlebt
ich war in meiner wohnung nicht weit von
ihr sieht auch aus wie hier
ich war im zweiten stock stark
geschüttelt
wie viele andere hat er danach die
nächte im freien verbracht zum glück
nicht im basecamp das einzige zählt das
in meinem comeback geschickt wurde war
mein büro zelt nicht dort gewesen wäre
wäre ich wohl verletzt ich hatte sicher
glück seine expedition mitglieder wurden
von der lawine verschont neben dem
everest yoursurprise verschiedene andere
expeditionen und trackings die mit
seiner agentur in nepal unterwegs sind
diesen anderen gilt nun seine größte
sorge denn die bergsteiger im basecamp
haben nahrung wasser und medizinische
versorgung all das fehlt den leuten
anderswo in nepal
[Musik]
für mich ist der everest nur ein kleiner
teil von liefern
aber ihr bekommt all die schlagzeilen
das ist etwas unglücklich denn die
gefahr ist dort vorbei
unglücklicherweise gab es viele tote
da können wir nichts machen das ist die
folge einer lawine die durch eine
naturkatastrophe
also das erdbeben ausgelöst wurde dieses
erdbeben hat tausende in kathmandu und
anderswo getötet da sind wir machtlos
aber wir schafften es alle verletzten
vom everest hierher in ein spital zu
bringen
das ist von mir aus abgeschlossen nicht
ein paar tage später wird die saison
2015 am everest abgebrochen und zwar
sowohl auf der süd wie auch auf der
nordseite und andrea und norden
sie waren vier tage von der umwelt
abgeschnitten
aber jetzt treffen wir sie in kathmandu
in ihrem gelben expedition zählt das ist
unser neues zuhause in den morgen
verbringen dem büro
wir essen dort auch schnelle hier
draußen schlafen wir das haus hat risse
in der nacht schüttelt es manchmal dann
schläft man drin schlecht ist sicher und
man schläft besser und andrea waren zum
zeitpunkt des erdbebens nicht hier in
ihrem büro sondern an der tibetischen
grenze in einem jeep begann zu schütteln
ich fragte den fahrer wie so schüttelt
es so strahlt er antwortete das ist wahr
ist was passiert und wir versuchten dort
hinzugehen
hier sieht man das haus ist noch ok am
nächsten tag war das haus weg da sieht
man noch die blauen stühle
überall gab es wissen was sie da es das
hat der regierungsrat ist ein privater
helikopter gewesen könnte man sagen die
zahlen aber in einem regierungs
helikopter sollten zuerst verwundete
mitgenommen werden für mich war es
schrecklich das mit eigenen augen zu
sehen
es war traurig
[Musik]
das beben hat die vielen pläne der
beiden völlig über den haufen geworfen
ich spürte und andrea auch dass wir
jetzt den leuten helfen müssen denn er
ist vergessen
der ist bleibt er steht auch nächstes
jahr noch dort im moment ist es
wichtiger etwas zu tun
wenigstens für einige leute ihre
tracking firma muss warten
die beiden wollen jetzt mit ihrem
hilfsprojekt helfen und das muss
organisiert seien unterwegs in kathmandu
ist auch russell price
er hat alle seine touren und
expeditionen annulliert er muss nun die
hotels informieren
[Musik]
aus angst vor nachbeben schlafen und
leben die leute draußen selbst in noblen
hyatt vor dem hotel hat das management
für seine angestellten deren familien
und für die gäste eine suppenküche
eingerichtet
[Musik]
russell wird vom manager im t shirt
erwartet und nicht wie gewohnt im anzug
ich komme zu ihnen denn wir haben viele
reservationen die wir leider annullieren
müssen für hotels gastgewerbe reisebüros
und deren angestellte ist das eine
katastrophe
ohne touristen kein einkommen und viele
touristen attraktionen wie der tara
hardturm liegen in trümmern
in den folgenden tagen normalisiert sich
auf den straßen von katmandu das leben
der lok wieder
[Musik]
andrea ist dabei eine hilf store aufs
land vorzubereiten
wir holen die es waren aus dem lager ist
das in ordnung
ja sie haben schon begonnen
andrea und novo wollen nach nepal talk
fahren einem kleinen dorf zweieinhalb
autostunden von der hauptstadt entfernt
hauptsächlich reis und ein paar andere
lebensmittel wollen sie dort verteilen
ein sack wiegt stolze 30 kilogramm
im rucksack und materiallager und machen
heute mittwoch 6
die lebensmittel verursachten kosten von
knapp 1000 dollar
[Musik]
händler
mit ihrem butterfly hell project wollten
die beiden scherb kinder unterstützen
nun helfen sie einem ganzen dorf auf dem
land dort ist hilfe auch dringender als
in kathmandu
schon ein paar kilometer westlich von
kathmandu ist die zerstörung noch größer
norbu und andrea erreichen sanco village
ein dorf mit knapp 1000 einwohnern
hier haben sie schon vor ein paar tagen
hilfe geleistet suncor village war einst
ein reiches handels dorf an der route
zwischen kathmandu und lhasa nun sieht
es aus als ob hier eine bombe
eingeschlagen hätte
80 prozent der häuser sind zerstört
in den trümmern sind freiwillige andere
arbeit es sind 30 studenten der aronia
high school von kathmandu hat er eine
persönliche beziehung zu diesem ort hier
in köln persönlich verbindung aber hier
hat das große zerstörungen
es kommt von herzen dass ich helfen wir
sind nun seit zwei tagen immer und
helfen noch bis morgen
das ist großartig ich gratuliere euch
wenn die helfer abgefahren sind muss die
dorfbevölkerung wohl alleine weiter
schauen
andrea und norbert fahren weiter es
sieht noch eineinhalb stunden bis nach
nizza top
kurz vor dem ziel wird die straße wegen
eines erdrutsches unbefahrbar es ist
okay wir sind nicht mehr weit weg vom
dorf die einheimischen wissen dank
morbus verbindungsmann dass hilfe kommt
sie sind bereits auf dem weg zu den
autos die hilfsgüter werden abgeladen
das ganze dorf hilft mit wie viele leute
haben wir 200 von 27 familien sind die
häuser total zerstört
weder ein helikopter am himmel ein
alltägliches bild seit dem erdbeben
noble stellt für jede der 27 familien
eine ration es waren zusammen
die dorfbewohner warten geduldig alle
häuser sind zerstört
das problem ist nun wir geben ihnen
nahrungsmittel aber sie haben keine
töpfe und pfannen mehr und zu kochen vor
ort zeigen sich immer wieder neue
bedürfnisse kleine freuden wie dieser
biscuit sind aber immer willkommen
[Gelächter]
andrea und norbert ihn mit ins zerstörte
dorf nippel talk
gerne jetzt das sieht sie zwei wochen
unterbrochen
wer schaut optisch durchaus und dem
internet und jetzt müssen sie einfach
weiter dass das dass sie mindestens
tasse hey sauber also ihre kultur
ableger
und die zwischenzeit ja aber so so schön
gemacht was ich sowieso nicht
die improvisierten häuser schützen kaum
vor der veteranen- oder in der nacht
kann es empfindlich kalt werden
umso wichtiger die decken die andrea
verteilt inhalt druck gab es zum glück
keine todesopfer zu beklagen
das mutet fast ein wenig wie ein wunder
an
angesichts der immensen zerstörung ein
dorfbewohner erklärt dass alle röser
seiner familie zerstört sind
ein trostloses bild
so war doch wir sind dann mal los che
guevara jojo
wie geht es für normal und andrea weiter
wird ihre tracking firma je gedeihen
wie können sie weiterhelfen wird das
geld reichen oder muss andrea zurück in
die schweiz
wie wird nepal überleben wir wissen es
nicht
die katastrophe ist noch lange nicht
ausgestanden
so endet diese geschichte wieder dort wo
sie begann bei der stupa in kathmandu wo
noch vor einem monat für viel glück am
everest gebetet hat
die über 1000-jährige stube hat einige
risse und die gebetsfahnen fehlen
vielleicht weiß butter wie es weitergeht
[Musik]